Model pemrograman adalah spesifikasi dasar yang mendefinisikan
bagaimana software disusun
dan dijalankan — model ini menyediakan kerangka kerja
bagi developer untuk mengekspresikan algoritma
dan mengorganisir kode, seringkali dengan menyembunyikan detail tingkat rendah
dari hardware maupun lingkungan eksekusi yang mendasarinya
berbeda model cocok untuk tipe masalah yang berbeda
dan arsitektur hardware yang berbeda, menawarkan
berbagai tingkat abstraksi
dan kontrol. Di bab ini
kita akan membahas model pemrograman kuantum dan klasik
dan melihat bagaimana kita bisa menggabungkannya untuk menjalankan algoritma
yang lebih canggih
kita mulai dengan model pemrograman
untuk komputer kuantum. Satu model pemrograman fundamental
yang sudah dikenal oleh hampir semua developer kuantum
adalah quantum circuit. Kita tidak akan membahas
detail dari quantum circuit
di sini karena kita sudah punya banyak sumber daya bagus
termasuk kuliah dari Joan Waters
kita hanya akan menyebutkan bahwa circuit dibangun dari
sekumpulan garis yang disebut wire yang merepresentasikan qubit
serta gate yang merepresentasikan operasi pada quantum state
dan sekumpulan pengukuran
konsep model pemrograman penting lainnya
adalah
primitif-primitif ini merepresentasikan task yang paling umum
yang ingin dicapai pengguna dengan komputer kuantum
ada dua primitif yang tersedia saat ini
Sampler dan Estimator. Sampler memberi kamu kemampuan
untuk mengambil sampel state yang dipersiapkan oleh quantum circuit
dan Estimator memungkinkan kamu mengestimasi nilai ekspektasi dari
sebuah observable untuk sistem dalam state yang dipersiapkan oleh quantum
circuit kamu. Konsep terakhir
yang akan kita bahas di bagian ini
adalah transpilasi. Transpilasi
adalah proses penulisan ulang circuit input yang diberikan
agar sesuai dengan topologi perangkat kuantum
tertentu
untuk dieksekusi pada komputer kuantum yang berisik
mirip dengan compiler klasik
sebuah rutinitas transpilasi secara bertahap mengubah
struktur circuit dengan menerapkan serangkaian pass
sekarang mari kita bicara tentang model pemrograman klasik
ada banyak model pemrograman
untuk komputer klasik
tapi di bab ini kita akan fokus pada dua
yang paling populer: pemrograman paralel
dan task workflow. Dengan menggunakan dua model ini
dikombinasikan dengan model pemrograman kuantum
kita bisa mengekspresikan hampir semua hybrid
workflow kuantum-klasik dengan kompleksitas apa pun
model pemrograman paralel
membagi sebuah program menjadi submasalah yang bisa dieksekusi
secara bersamaan. Ada dua paradigma utama dalam pemrograman paralel
shared memory parallelism dan distributed memory parallelism
untuk keperluan kita di sini, mari fokus pada model distributed memory
sebuah model distributed memory
menggunakan proses-proses independen pada core terpisah
atau node, di mana setiap proses punya memorinya sendiri
dan komunikasi terjadi melalui message passing. Ada
beberapa konsep yang perlu kamu ketahui
yang pertama adalah proses
yaitu instance independen dari program
yang berjalan pada core terpisah
lalu ada rank, yaitu identifier unik dari proses tersebut
dan kemudian ada single program
multiple data, model abstraksi
yang merupakan model abstraksi
untuk komputasi di mana satu instance program
didistribusikan ke banyak node
jadi source code-nya sama
tapi data di node-node tersebut berbeda
eksekusi dalam model pemrograman paralel
terjadi dengan cara berikut
sebuah program tunggal didistribusikan ke beberapa node
dan memulai beberapa proses paralel
alur kontrol program ditentukan oleh rank
atau identifier dari proses tersebut
dan komunikasi terjadi
melalui message passing
model pemrograman task workflow
mengabstraksikan komputasi ke dalam sebuah graph atau DAG
di mana setiap node dalam graph adalah task tertentu
atau job, dan edge-nya adalah dependensi serta urutan data
dan contoh-contohnya bisa kamu temukan di dokumentasi kami
lagipula urutan yang selalu kita bicarakan dalam kuantum
computing: mapping, optimisasi
eksekusi, dan post-processing
itu adalah model pemrograman task workflow
di mana semua task dieksekusi satu per satu
dalam sebuah pipeline
tapi dengan task workflow
kita tidak terikat pada urutan eksekusi sekuensial
dan bisa menjalankan task secara paralel
setiap task atau workflow bisa menjadi job paralel tersendiri
sehingga kamu bisa memadukan
dan menggabungkan model-model ini untuk mendeskripsikan algoritma
dengan kompleksitas apa pun.
Sekarang kita coba terapkan beberapa konsep yang sudah kita pelajari
ke dalam kode. Pertama kita akan mencoba menjalankan hello world sederhana
menggunakan paradigma pemrograman paralel
kita akan menggunakan Open MPI
yang merupakan implementasi dari protokol MPI
yaitu standar untuk message passing
dalam pemrograman paralel
pertama kita perlu menyiapkan program kita
di sini kita menggunakan mpi4py
yang merupakan binding Python
untuk MPI dan seperti yang bisa kamu lihat kita menggunakan rank di sini untuk menentukan
alur kontrol program
sekarang mari kita cek submission script kita.
Seperti yang bisa kamu lihat kita akan menggunakan dua node
satu task per node di partisi normal
dan sekarang kita jalankan program kita, kita tunggu sebentar
dan kita bisa cek hasil job kita
seperti yang bisa kamu lihat, kita punya log output dari program kita
di sini kita menggunakan dua node dan dua proses
yang diidentifikasi dengan rank
seperti yang terlihat di sini sebagai output
rank nol dan rank satu yang digunakan untuk menentukan
alur kontrol program kita
seperti yang bisa kamu lihat proses rank nol mengirim
payload tertentu ke proses rank satu
dan proses rank satu menerimanya
sekarang kita juga akan membahas tentang task workflow
ada tools yang disebut work
load management system yang dirancang khusus
untuk menjalankan workflow yang kompleks
tapi agar tidak terlalu membebani, kita akan menggunakan fitur dependency bawaan
di Slurm
untuk menyusun kelompok komputasi tersebut
pertama kita perlu menyiapkan task-task workflow kita
ini kodenya. Ini adalah kode yang sama
keuntungan dari memisahkan setiap task ini
sebagai mapping, optimisasi, eksekusi
dan post-processing menjadi langkah-langkah terpisah
adalah kita bisa menentukan kebutuhan resource yang unik
untuk setiap task. Misalnya mapping, optimisasi
dan post-processing tidak membutuhkan
akses ke resource kuantum
sehingga kita bisa menjalankannya di partisi klasik.
Tapi task eksekusi akan membutuhkan
resource kuantum, jadi kita akan menjalankannya di partisi kuantum
partition.
Sekarang kita gunakan fitur dependency untuk menghubungkan task-task
menjadi sebuah workflow.
Seperti yang bisa kamu lihat kita masih menjalankan
perintah sbatch kita dengan flag --parsable
yang akan mengembalikan job ID-nya
dan kemudian kita bisa mengoper job ID ini
sebagai dependency ke task-task lain
untuk job-job tersebut. Seperti yang bisa kamu lihat kita menjalankan
job-job dalam workflow dengan dependency-nya
setelah seluruh workflow selesai kita bisa cek hasilnya.
Dan seperti yang bisa kamu lihat kita sudah mendapatkan nilai ekspektasi kita kembali.
Dan kita juga bisa mengecek semua
hasil dari setiap langkah.
Yang juga ada di sini.
Dan itu tadi untuk bagian model pemrograman
di bab berikutnya kita akan membahas tentang algoritma lanjutan
gritters